this week conflict zone is in the
estonian capital Tallinn
to meet Georgia fleen who sits in the
European Parliament for Hungary's
governing fetish party on April 8 Prime
Minister Viktor Orban was reelected
using rhetoric described as intimidating
and cinah phobic will that kind of
nationalist vision decide the future of
Europe
[Music]
Joe Chaplin welcome to conflict zone
your Prime Minister Viktor Orban was
just re-elected to a third consecutive
turn the Organization for Security and
Cooperation SCE said the opposition did
not really have a chance to compete yes
well it's their job yes it's a chance
they did have a chance and they actually
got I thought exactly how many votes but
they the cool best part of two million
votes fidel 2.7 that tells me that there
is competition and besides you know they
have to say things like that that's
their job why the criticism is not their
job the OSC is he is a neutral
organization and very well respected the
report said quote intimidating and
sinner phobic rhetoric media bias Anna
Park campaign financing and of the quote
hidden that voters ability to make an
informed choice this was not a fair
election was it I think it was a very
fair election I was there for the whole
of the campaign I didn't see
intimidation and I wasn't just sitting
in Budapest objective finish yeah but
Norrell they there's no such thing as
objectivity I don't believe in fairy
tales either do you think that the
Aussie is objective no no do you think
that anybody is objective do you think
that even it is not subjective the us
see he said these elections were not
fair Hungary is member which means that
you accept the standards of this
organization do you accept the standards
of this organization we do accept the
standards and I think that they are see
got it wrong
but if you accept the standards this
means that you have to accept also their
criticism seriously we take the
criticism seriously I think always grey
zones where interpretation comes into
the picture I think they came along as
usual with a certain set of ideas about
how Hungary is that they get that from
the Western media the Western media
listen only
the opposition so they ignore the gray
zone of interpretation that's okay we're
used to that but this is not really an
answer the head of the observer mission
that this wake said there was a purse a
sieve of Allah between state and ruling
party resources which undermined the
ability of opposition candidates to
compete equally having democratic
elections mean not tilting the scales
look the scales are always tilted to
some degree depending on what the
population the voters I really want oh
yes it's not cynical for Democrats I
don't think it's silly Cole I think it's
realistic I mean think about it so this
high a cynical to be cynical as
realistic not invariably I mean you know
what the word cynically is it's doglike
behavior I don't think I'm a dog here's
morality something in politics morality
and politics are obviously linked and
obviously equally obviously morality is
something that must always movement to
question otherwise you get into what is
known in the trade as monism a single
concept of morality which is
anti-democratic that's the Soviet Union
let's speak about the Free Press
this is constitutional for the amicus
for the amok recei yes journalists were
pressured state broadcaster biased and
governed messages campaigns overlap with
your parties if that's what you call
fair the freedom of press I would not
call that fair but then that's the only
one opinion of how things are in Hungary
if you look at the entire picture of the
media there's enormous diversity the
trouble is you see that other than
Hungarians nobody knows Hungarian so
they can't do a proper content analysis
country to understand if the standards
of Free Press are given or not well I
think it really helps if you actually do
know something about the country don't
this is a really problem to judge about
certain scales and standards I think
there is a real problem I read what
happens let's say in Venezuela but I
don't really know because I have to take
the word of the journalists the
interpreter
who tell me and they have a bias they're
not objective let's talk about migration
because this was the overwhelming
campaign issue during the campaign sorry
Prime Minister Obon says quote we do not
consider these people as Muslim refugees
we consider them Muslim invaders do you
agree I think he said economic migrants
and he does he has said in the past I
was present when he said this that there
are three types of people coming to
Europe there are genuine political
refugees asylum seekers there are
economic migrants and there are fighters
we know I'm speaking about invaders
don't vote I agree that there are Muslim
invaders it depends on how you define
invasion if you define invasion in this
instance a peaceful invasion then I
think it's clearly the case at very
large numbers of people arrived in
Hungary without so much as buy or leave
in 2015 Mott's through the country this
was traumatic you know what invaders
means there is a connotation with the
word this is hate speech if you say
Muslim invaders this is hate speech
isn't it no I don't think it is so what
is hate speak well that's Muslims the
Muslims generalisation invaders we know
how these pictures are used
everybody generalizes you generalize I
German don't generalize if I speak about
groups especially religion groups I'm
sorry so not your Prime Minister
generalized not only saying the Muslims
but he is also adding invaders what a
picture you know what this mean well I
think Islands I think what you mean that
isn't necessarily the same as what orbán
means and secondly of course there are
collectivities as we make generalized
judgments about them religious groups
just as much as secular ones invaders
means aggression you have a lot of
potential of threatening people
do you believe that the Muslim groups as
he said are invaders what I saw in 2015
when I was there was structural violence
something against which nothing could be
done it was a flood of people who were
paying no attention to what they were
doing if you want to call this
innovation you can call it innovation
you could also call it a tide you can
use all sorts of men spoke speak about
refugees migrants he said Muslim yes I
think that the great majority if not a
hundred percent or some Christians they
were overwhelmingly Muslim you a member
of the European Parliament article 21 of
the European charter clearly states
quote any discrimination based on any
grounds such as religion or belief shall
be prohibited Muslim invaders if that is
not a religious discrimination then what
is but if you're quoting the Charter of
Fundamental Rights acne fine please
recall article one which is about human
dignity and here the human dignity of
the Hungarian population is every bit as
important as that of the Muslim we do
you believe that in Hungary
this is today's reality Muslim invaders
millions could come to angry are in
angry and want to suppress your people
speaking about Hungary I understand that
but you have to see to the European
context possibly a global context it's
no question the large numbers of people
in the world are on the move
Hungary I think experienced this
profound shock in 2015 and there are
there a lot at this particular time very
large numbers of drawsome Muslims were
not very many in Hungary what the great
majority of Hungarians do not want
there's no fooling figures to back this
up is that there should be a lot of
rules everything fair enough that we are
now in 2018 and these quotes are also
partly coming from the election campaign
2018 so what's about today you still
believe that there could be a Muslim
invasion in your country yes I think I
wouldn't use the word invasion which is
one the jury loved live no it's your
Prime Minister wasn't allowed you keep
you keep quoting it they want to take
away our country who exactly who exactly
mr. schaffner wants to take away your
country I think the very large number of
refugees who may potentially want to
settle in Hungary aided and abetted by
Western liberals and they want to take
away your country they want to transform
the country in such a way that it's no
longer recognizable to the great
majority of people who live there at
this time right you're only on one hand
your Prime Minister always said nobody
of these refugees wants to stay in
Hungary they want to go to Germany on
the other hand you are telling your
people that every Muslim wants to stay
in Hungary I don't understand the
logical argumentation do you think we're
saying every lot I mean foreigners wants
to take away our country this is a
quantity this is a certain quantity we
don't know exactly how many but we
really don't want to find out you
proposed you proposed watching pig heads
on the border fences to determine masks
yes I did I did tweet this quite right
what was the idea behind them well it
all began with some pictures or I think
mosques which I saw as being a per to
page so I said well why stay with masks
why not put our pigs heads this was
criticized to be racist and a degrading
idea yes was it racist I don't think it
is I think it's looking at the way in
which for Islam walk pigs are haram
unacceptable a form of pollution and
therefore to say to them look if you
come to Hungary you will find the people
eat pig people eat pork in Hungary the
abelian spec do you respect the Islam
religion do I respect respect this
religion I've done what you mean by
respect here of course it exists is this
religion as respectable as Christianity
or Jewish Judaism I have some problems
with Islamic theological doc do you want
the Christianity is respected I would
like to see a Christianity this
respected I think that's right do you
know that for example your idea with the
pig heads is also racist and a degrading
idea for Jews fully aware ever so was it
also a message to Jews because it was
not clear to assume the message was
given I think it was clear in the
context I mean it was about that on the
fence and it was facing the migrants
coming towards Hungary I think was very
clear I have said elsewhere that one of
the responsibilities of the present
government in Hungary is to protect the
third largest Jewish Parmenides rude
rude yeah I think to to express know for
a cultivated person as you are to use
pigs you know what this means for people
who are Jews or Muslims or don't you
know I have an idea you know oh you have
an idea I have a fairly good idea
although some will not take it quite as
seriously as you are at this moment as
you have to decide to do it it's one
thing but how seriously it is taken this
is also something you know oh you are
suddenly very naive no I'm not I'm
simply saying the subjective perception
over phenomenon will always vary I have
no idea how a non-religious Jew would
respond yes no idea I've no idea because
they vary amongst themselves religious
attempt only it is also a principled
attempt for Jew of foreign aid Muslim
the principle take care is Nazis
anti-semitic people are throwing Pig
at the synagogue to describe their
disrespect
now it's offense not to hunger if at all
not in hungry
there is no anti-semitism and angry very
little very little are you really sure
that's what the surveys tell me that's
what the reality is not telling me the
World Jewish Congress for example was
very clear on that that not only Hungary
and your government has a problem with
Muslims but also with Jews I think the
World Jewish Congress is in error in
this respect that is an error this is
the first government of Hungary the
second all of our government which
recognized that Hungary was responsible
in part for the Holocaust doesn't mean
that you learn something in the present
time well this is I think very real and
I think the various Jewish communities
isn't a single Jewish community in
Hungary accepted this and regarded it as
positive I was there at that particular
occasion there's no question in my mind
that you will find individuals around
you some idiots talk about the
anti-semitism or the alleged
anti-semitism of the campaign of your
prime minister I would like to talk
about in Hungarian excited Soros it was
almost as if and the most recent
election of Prime Minister was running
against him he compared sorrows to the
invading armies of the Turks Soviets and
Hobbes books rollers saying Soros allies
in Hungary would face revenge revenge
for what and why so us the translators
have let you down the word isn't revenge
its immense Alec theater is the
Hungarian word so don't always believe
what the journalists tell you as far as
Soros is concerned I think this is a
superb electoral trap set by Fidesz
basically in effect making show us the
symbolic leader of the Opposition which
means that the bulk of Hungarian voters
will not vote for him Albin also
promised to send Soros quote home even
though they are Garin born Finnish he
has not been in the country for years
what did open me
sending home this is a symbolic Siraj
not the real individual it's a symbolic
one as I know we have individuals for
what the symbolic Sirach is a symbol
right yes this there are individuals for
whom Shero symbolizes what liberalism of
a particular kind certainly visceral
opposition to Fidesz visceral opposition
to or ban it's a part of this was sent
home they hadn't been sent home
it was simply I think part of a campaign
rhetoric I don't think anybody will be
sent home but as you probably know open
society is currently thinking about
moving to Berlin me I thought that in
democracies opposition's are not sent
home they are part of home but a lot of
the debate around mr. Soros and his
influence has descended into lines of
argument about quote International
Finance which is a code word used by
anti-semites you remember also by the
Nazis mr. Soros is Jewish Viktor Orban
who is a very intelligent man do we
agree we must know which flames he was
feigning when he played with
anti-semitic stereotypes during his
campaign I don't see it as anti-semitic
I think you could give it that reading
but I think it was much more about the
finance and sure as you knew has
actually been find in France for his
speculation he took a million pounds off
the Bank of England I'm a British tax
mr. Albin is also not a very let me say
socialist person he loves to make
businesses but this what you're telling
us is is years ago we are today why does
he play with the International Finance
picture you can't scrub history entirely
we're all made of our own past you and
be included really because this has
happened 15-20 years ago doesn't mean
that it lacks a reality today it does
look a dress Heisler the chairman of the
Hungarian Jewish Federations called
on mr. Albin to end the campaign using
the sasori's picture the organization
said it was a proxy
anti-semitism I'm gonna understand that
I can understand that Heisler would want
to say this because of course he is in
touch with the World Jewish Congress and
so on and they are concerned but it
seems to me that there's a real danger
of anti-semitism in countries where
there's a large Muslim minority not in
Hungary do you know do you remember
being an academic and historian that
anti-semitism existed also in East
Europe also an angry before refugees
came three years ago you remember that
also in your country before they came
you had problems I wanted only to add
that to your comment and I cuz it looks
like that anti-semitism of today the
anti-semitism of Muslims alone can I
answer this please I was there when the
Holocaust took place I was four years
old I remember seeing people with yellow
stars I wasn't old enough to watch the
trains pulling out of the brick factory
for house roots of course I know I know
all this I worked on this but at the
same time I do not believe that
everything can be written down as
anti-semitism there are different
interpretations and the way in which the
campaign was wrong which certainly has
certainly been seen as anti-semitic by
various people it doesn't mean it was
and mr. o'hanlan from Human Rights Watch
said I'm coming back to your Pig you
words are disgusting I would expect that
from anonymous neo-nazi trolls but you
are an MEP act like one
he's wrong he's disgusting I think he
also called me human filth that's Nazi
language it's hate speech well at that
point the argument ceases it's no longer
an argument that's interesting you are
very clear about a judgement this cooked
but you can't be as clear about yourself
with Pig heads
look as far as a big herds of pigs heads
are concerned I think I've made my
position fairly clear what I thought
as a thought experiment an experiment of
thought experiment so what experiment
use many people took it for real so I
got a whole flood of hate mail ship
shore line was the launch launch pad I
imagine one doesn't really know where
tweets come from but it happened I'm I'm
a sadder and wiser person I want to try
to understand your fear how many
Hungarians are there it is very
difficult to say if it were exactly the
Hungarian but we generally count about
thirteen and a half million but then
there are people in the United States of
Hungarian descent who say they are
Hungarian and they can actually ten
million more or less a bit more than
that okay how many Muslims live in
Hungary twenty thousand not even zero
point percent Viktor Orban says he wants
to keep Europe Christian do you agree I
agree with this yes so no Muslims
Muslims yes if they accept the dominant
norms which are derived from
Christianity Christian Europe Christian
what's about Jews Jews fine they're fine
yeah it's because the judeo-christian
tradition that we're looking at
Christianity has taken a great deal from
Judaism the relationship between
Christians and Jews as I know has been
bloody Christian persecuted and killed
Jews up until the Second Vatican Council
I think I couldn't agree with you more
this is a fairly shameful part of
European history on the other hand at
this particular time I think relations
between Christians and Jews have never
been better
I have a question you're a member of the
European Union right the Parliament but
Hungary is still a member of the
European Union
when I left Strasbourg yesterday the
answer was yes yes so the Friedmann
freedom of movement is one of the
pillars of the idea of BU correct yes
if European of Muslim faced want to move
to Hungary will you stop that no we
can't stop them and if thousands will
come
absolutely true so what's about your
Christianity well that point you know we
have to confront the problem and look at
it see what's to be done about it
as I say there is a small Muslim
community already in Hungary Park the
Sunni politician you have family fled as
I know a totalitarian regime and settled
in Britain mm-hmm
why should that not apply to the people
facing persecution to people facing
persecution it does apply to it's the
economic migrants that I'm told this
area area for some of the people from
Syria or economic micro the majority of
Syrian refugees are they fleeing by the
reason of war so I do precisely because
I haven't done any field work on this we
also know that the majority are in
Turkey in Lebanon and Jordan I asked you
again do you really think that the
majority of Syrian refugees are not
fleeing because of war and because they
are persecuted not so quite this
definite about this is your I don't know
their motivations but I'm a chance as a
chance was given also to you and you
attend took a chance I think that's
right I'm quite prepared to believe that
yes it is and Christians are definitely
fleeing because of fear for the fear of
their lives whether all the Sunnis or so
doing in the same way I don't know the
answer to that if somebody is a refugee
do you ask him after he enters the
country or before asylum seekers as they
enter the country and if somebody is
saying I'm fleeing yes because of the
war in Syria what are you doing then
well you say no ask them to make a case
part of the problem in 2015 with a very
large number of people coming with for
Syrian passports they were Bangladeshis
Pakistanis or Africans do you think that
Europe is endangered by the refugee
crisis no Europe is actually in danger
because of itself
because it's lost confidence here what
it wants to be is completely divided and
I'm somewhat concerned as to where
Europe is headed for the next fight that
Hungary has a small responsibility about
this Hungary I think has a
responsibility in the same way as any
other country of the same size and I
think the responsibility is to offer an
alternative to the hyper liberalism that
is running Europe today nationalism at
the answer nationhood is the answer
thank you for being a conflict zone mr.
sheply it was a pleasure having you with
me thank you so much thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]